Mesdames, mesdemoiselles, messieurs...
Le maître de cérémonie de la 40ème Nuit des Césars de la Philosophie...
Platon !
WOOOOH
Platon ! Platon ! Platon ! ...
Merci ! Merci ! Bienvenue à tous pour cette 40ème cérémonie des Césars de la Philosophie.
Ça me fais vraiment plaisir d'être là et vous vous êtes magnifique avec vos toges de soirée.
En plus, ça fais un bail que l'on ne s'est pas vu et pour ça je vous ai préparé une cérémonie un petit peu spéciale.
Dans la catégorie de la philosophie la plus malsaine, les nommés sont Sigmund Freud,
"-Je me sens vachement suivi en ce moment
-Mmh. Vous devriez coucher avec votre mère"
... Sigmund Freud,
"-Docteur... J'entends des voix dans ma tête
-... Vous devriez coucher avec votre mère"
... et Sigmund Freud
"-J'ai l'impression que tout le monde me regarde
-Mh. Vous prenez plaisir à faire caca ?
-Pardon ?
-Est ce que vous aimez lorsque votre anus se dilate pour laisser passer cette masse énorme,
qu'est votre merde ?
-Non.
-Mh. Ben vous devriez coucher avec votre mère"
Et le César est attribué à... Sigmund Freud !
Et le César de la phrase qu'on a essayé de comprendre mais qu'on n'est pas sûrs d'avoir comprise est attribué à Hegel pour:
"Si maintenant devient présente à la conscience dans son œuvre l'opposition du vouloir et de l'accomplir,
du but et des moyens..."
Le César du meilleur costume est attribué à Diogène.
-Merci ! Le costume c'est ma maison aussi
I need this !
Le César de l’honnêteté est remis à Socrate !
-Moi les gars je sais que je ne saurais.
Bravo ! Wooh ! Bravo Socrate !
Le César du meilleur espoir: Franck Ribéry
-Ah... Je pas trop savoir que je sache
J'adore ce qu'il fait
César du meilleur cadreur
*bruit de marteau*
*applaudissements*
César de la meilleur bande originale
César du philosophe le plus ouvert: Karl Popper
*sniffe*
César du philosophe le plus visionnaire: Jean-Paul Sartre.
César Döner:
Tu veux du ketchup ou tu veux de la moutarde ?
"... dans son ensemble de la réalité fictive elle même l'unité et la nécessité de cette opération n'en sont
pas moins également présentes..."
Pour le César de la mort la plus cocasse, les nommés sont Sénèque, mort dans son bain,
Épicure, mort dans son bain...
-Encore un peu d'eau chaude ?
-Nan c'est bon
... Claude François, mort dans son bain.
Aaaarh. Toudoudou.
Pour le César de la citation qui est devenu un pur tatouage de bauf, les nommés sont "Carpe Diem"
de Lucrèce, "Le cœur a ses raisons que la raison ignore" de Pascal, "Ce qui ne te tue pas, te rend plus fort" de Nietzsche, et enfin, "Only God can judge me" de Tupac.
"... ce côté chevauche sur l'autre et l'expérience de la contingence de l'opération *ronflement* est elle même seulement une expérience contingente"
Hegel.
Merci beaucoup pour ce César. Je voudrai remercier deux ou trois personnes.
Euh... Je voudrai... commencer par...
On m'entend toujours là ?
Vous me voyez ?
Je voudrai remercier ceux qui vont partager cette vidéo et mes parents,
ceux qui vont s'abonner à ma chaîne et mes parents,
ceux qui vont cliquer sur les autres vidéos et...
-Monsieur Hegel ! C'est bon. Je pense qu'on a compris. Merci à tous ceux qui ont suivi cette cérémonie. Nous rendons l’Athènes.